فيروس كورونا السيناري الذي يصيب القطع
شائع جدا ولا يسبب عاده اي مشكلات خطيره
باستثناء الاسهال الخفيف ثم يمضي لحاله
بعد فتره من اسبوع الى عشره ايام الازمه
عندما يتطور فيروس كورونا القطط الى سلاله
معينه متحور يعرف باسم اف اي بي عندها
يصبح قاتلا على الاغلب اعراض المرض تتشابه
مع فيروسات اخرى وتشمل تورم البطن وفقدان
الطاقه والشهيه والسلوك العدواني في بعض
الاحيان لكن الفيروس لا ينتقل من القطط
المصابه الى الانسان هناك لقاحات متوفره
لعلاج المرض لكن لم تثبت فعاليه كبيره ولا
تزال تحت التجارب والدراسه ولا يوصى بها
من قبل اللجان الصحيه المختصه في امريكا
عموما ينصحب الاطباء بمتابعه الحاله
الصحيه لقطتك المنزليه باستمرار وابقاء
اطباق طعامهم وشربهم بعيده عن صناديق
القمامه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات